(upbeat music)
- Bill, how much time,
how much time do I have?
Perfect.
And how many people will be in attendance,
you think, roughly?
Fantastic.
(upbeat music)
- You wanna get the most
awkwardly placed bathroom?
- Nice to see you again.
- Good to see you again.
- How you been?
- All well?
- All well.
- Good.
- Nice to see you.
- How are you?
(upbeat music)
- Sup man, I'm Ben.
- Hey, Sean.
- Sean, nice to meet you.
- Hey, Andy.
- Andy, what's up?
- Hey, how are you?
- We started kinda with business
and then we went like let's go broader,
like let's take your
sort of point of view,
the motivation, the tough
love, the whole sort of like,
the broader sort of value
and apply to, yeah, business
but also like other things
that people are trying to--
- We get most of our
experience like MTV MADE.
Getting a 16-year-old to get
the prom date that he wants.
- Frankly, those are higher concepts.
There's a lot more production,
there's a lot more moving pieces.
You gotta cast the right people.
You gotta go on location, it
takes up a lot of your time.
- And I have a fun belief that
a lot of the people you're talking to
talent-wise
are gonna need that to carry the day.
And I don't.
- That's totally agree.
So like...
- Just give me some Snapcash.
(laughs)
And let my team look
through 10 thousand kids
pitching 10-second ideas
and then I'll watch a hundred of them
and say, "You've won, Andy".
You know what's crazy, Sean?
Like, thank God, I'm
in such a better place
to produce this show
than I was a month ago.
Because I've been living on the platform.
And reacting.
- It's making an impact.
I mean you've seen it.
You knew what you were doing.
It worked.
- I know.
(laughs)
- I've dragged the entire 25 --
- The amount of people.
- to 50 year old marketing
world into Snapchat.
And I told them and they know this.
I did know what I was doing
but I just more wanted
to be on the record.
I've been completely pumped,
like, so thankful, I didn't,
and I was telling them the truth.
What I didn't quantify was,
all the people that follow me
have now gotten bigger themselves
and their audiences.
So it was more of a windfall
than things that have
happened in my past career
to some of these people that were big.
I'm really excited about
what's happening because,
for example, Brandon
Marshall just texted me,
he's coming over and the
whole conversation right now
is gonna be me putting him on Snapchat.
- It's funny you say that because
he's literally one of the best,
I assume he'll be a broadcasting legend
before it's all -- he's great.
- Like literally,
- He's a great person.
- Literally, in 15 minutes
like that's what's gonna happen.
I'm gonna be putting up content
everyday alongside of it.
To create context for this audience.
- Yeah.
- You know?
We're just gonna make the show better.
- That's what you're
saying like it's in a great
because we were talking about,
"Oh behind the scenes", stuff
like the behind the scenes
stuff happens naturally
because you're just already
on the platform talking to everyone.
- It's why everybody
loves what's going on with
DailyVee and Snapchat 'cause I'm doing
stuff on Snapchat and it shows on Vee
like that's been the
biggest comment right now
with DailyVee, they're like,
Oh shit, that's so cool 'cause I saw
that Snapchat happen live and then
now I see contextually what it meant.
There's a lot of that.
I'm so purely true to this world,
I'm like on the short list,
I know this for fact,
for Sharks, like I vet like seven people.
I don't wanna do that.
I wanna do this.
- Yeah.
- Now, if you thinking a four
to eight minute environment,
we can and should--
- Also, this can trans,
like this could be developed
into a TV concert that you could run with.
- Dude, dude, I don't give a fuck.
- But this is bigger.
It's gonna be much bigger.
- I don't wanna be on TV.
I wanna be on Snapchat.
- Alright, so I know what we need to do.
I know what we need to do.
- Hey man, get in here.
- Sup?
- We got bills to pay?
- I just don't understand
these deductions, man.
- How are ya?
- Come on, man.
- Meet everybody.
- How you guys doing?
- Good, good, good, good.
- Sean.
- Brandon.
- Hey.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Andy] Brandon.
- Sit down, sit down.
- What's man, Ben.
- Brandon.
- Andy.
- Nice to meet you, Brandon.
- Hey, Emile.
- How you doing?
- Brandon, Sean's from Snapchat.
- Oh, really?
- And actually that's what I
wanna talk to you about today.
Well we got one, we got two
separate things to talk about.
You're in the off-season now huh?
(laughs)
(mumbles)
- Right now I have like,
200 grams of sugar a day.
(laughs)
- I'm ready to go on this show.
- Yeah, we're on.
We're on.
I'm psyched.
So...
- We'll accelerate it.
Yeah.
- So, you're not a
Philadelphia sports fan?
- No.
- What do you like?
- No, no, I'm a Giants fan.
I'm a Giants fan.
(laughs)
(people talking over each other)
- The Jets-Giants game?
- Yeah.
- And see Brandon's game tying--
- I saw some of it.
- Sent to overtime.
(laughs)
I was just saying that I
think you're gonna be like
in the Broadcasting Hall of Fame.
- Yeah.
I hope you're starting,
I swear to God.
- But everybody's gassing you up.
I know you're a big football--
- (laughs) I know right.
- I know you're a good player.
We all know that.
- I just left actually, Inside
the NFL, we just taped it.
- What happened your Pacman Jones
interview was really good?
- Yeah it was really good.
- I need to see it.
- Supposedly but--
- Did you get--
- The interesting thing is
what everyone likes is the
interaction between player to player.
- 'Cause it's such a different dynamic.
- But for me,
it was like having a
conversation in a locker room.
- [Gary] Of course.
So, I was like, oh it's
just a regular conversation.
- There's not a lot of active players
doing it at that serious of a level
which adds a different dynamic
because everybody knows
it's a little different.
- [Brandon] Yeah.
- I love Chris Webber's commentary.
'Cause it just has that vibe,
it doesn't seem like he's bullshitting.
- [Gary] Yeah.
- It just feels real.
- Yeah.
- [Andy] He loved basketball.
- I do love basketball.
- I appreciate that compliment,
I'll write that down.
- In other years, this
team that we just had.
I would have been like well,
we wouldn't have beaten this team.
Like, fucking wide the fuck open.
That fucking hurt man.
I had a flight at fucking
L.A. after that Buffalo game.
- Yeah.
- Connected in Chicago.
Landed in L.A. at two in
the morning L.A. time.
Which is five a.m.
so I had to mope
my fucking ass.
(laughs)
From that to like ehh.
I was stunned how much that
felt like a play-off game.
- Yeah.
- The Buffalo game.
- The Buffalo game?
- Yeah.
- So just like, as
somebody who has been to
every Jets play-off game since 91.
That felt like a play-off game.
- Really?
- Mhmm.
- I thought the...
New England game--
- [Gary] Was crazy.
- Felt more like a playoff
game than a Buffalo game.
- I think for me, it wasn't even close.
- Like I had to really fight.
- I get it.
- I had like bro like, I was
spent after that game.
Like I was, everything I had, everything.
So throughout the week,
I had to really find--
- Yeah.
- Find energy bro, like...
- Snapchat. Let's do this
before you leave.
You have to do this.
- Well I will do it, not now.
Now now.
- Why, you're scared?
- No not any more.
- I'm about to make a Snapchat
about you being scared.
(laughs)
That's what I'm doing.
Brandon, tell everybody why
you're scared of Snapchat?
- Hey man, Snapchat boy is
too much action on Snapchat.
(laughs)
- What are you building up?
Your Twitter, your Instagram?
- I'm not trying to do anything really,
I mean, I'm on Instagram and on (mumbles).
- More people watch your Snapchat than
watch you on fucking Inside the NFL.
- Yeah.
- Like, it's just bigger
than you think, man.
- I know it is.
- And you're fucking
photogenic and charismatic,
and fucking creative and liked,
and you're just like, you need to,
whatever it takes for me to
like get you around this,
you have to wrap your head around this.
- No I'm gonna eventually do it.
- [Voiceover] Snapchat,
boy, there's too much
action on Snapchat.
(laughs)
- People like die from
it, it's just silly.
You know why Snapchat's great?
It doesn't have to be perfect,
it just needs to be real.
- Yeah.
- I'm tellin' you man, you've got,
there's so many people
winning that don't have
what you have, it's just like, you know,
if you wanna be entrepreneurial,
make stuff happen, you'll
have 100 people in your gym
if you do Snapchat.
What do you think every
fucking 18 to 22-year-old's
looking at?
- I know.
- I'm telling you man, please
don't be friends with me
and not be good at social media,
that's just the stupidest thing.
(laughs)
Like do you know what I mean?
Like that's a real stupid
mistake, makes no sense.
- I know it.
Oh man.
- Do you know what's
going on with DJ Kahled?
- Yeah.
They don't want you to be here with Gary!
You know what we're gonna do?
We're gonna be here with Gary.
(laughs)
- What's the scrap?
- [Matt] We're fine,
you're just not gonna film.
- Yeah, okay.
I gotta film the CM thing real quick.
Maybe I'll do that real quick?
- [DRock] No, I need you
first, before you do that.
- Can I meet with the
important people ASAP?
- They were in today.
They were in today,
they're going to be back
possibly later this week.
- Fuck. Okay.
- You're not, right?
- Okay.
I'll keep you posted on
when you can do that.
(beeps) who do you want
me to connect them to?
- I've got it. It's in my inbox.
- (beeps) Snapchat.
- Yes.
- There's an opportunity coming up.
The money's not gonna be there.
- That's okay, this is political.
- Wonderful.
- Cool, cool, thank you.
- You wanna fly to Boston
or you wanna take the train?
- I like both.
Whichever's fastest.
- [Matt] Well the plane is fastest,
but I know you like to take the train.
- No, I don't have minutes anymore.
Minutes are gone.
- Minutes are gone?
- I think you should
probably leave at 5:30.
- Yeah, I will 100% be in
the car at 5:30.
- Okay, then I'm cool with that.
- What are you guys doing here?
- Big meeting.
- Yeah, it looks like a big meeting.
But Choice is in it, so
it can't be that legit.
Go ask Tyler.
Actually, open the door
and ask Tyler, right now.
Interrupt that meeting and ask Tyler
what it felt like to have Gary drop
the gamewinner in your mouth.
- [Tyler] That's the first thing
he brought up this morning.
- Yeah, it was a really good one, too.
- I picked him up at half court
like the five possessions before that.
And then the one I don't,
and I get a piece on it,
and it couldn't have been more money.
- [DRock] He's talking
to Eric, book stuff.
- What's up?
- So you have nothing else
brewing in London right now?
- I'm having conversations,
but nothing that I'm like--
We're not that far out,
that's the other thing,
is that we're two months away.
- Literally walk your pretty face
with the great new beard up to Andrew
and be like, Andrew, I
need a BSU for London.
Anything interesting?
- Potentially at least 2,000
out of the Barter page already.
- [Gary] That are like
things that you think
will end up happening?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] That's great.
- It's massive.
- Brown's here?
Okay.
Brown University's here, I need to
get my daughter into Brown.
- [Voiceover] Gabe.
- [Gary] Gabe?
Gary.
How are you?
Hello.
I remember thinking about this,
and I knew I had to fly out, I'm like,
okay, if everyone's late and
I only have one thing to say,
if we get together, I'm
gonna say the following:
if you do not separate
the people that were lucky
to have mom and dad do the right thing
and they have no debt from
the people that literally
have hundreds of thousands of debt
that they can't even use
bankruptcy to get out of,
if you do not separate heavily
the way you communicate
to those two groups, you have no shot.
It makes no sense.
It just, you need, and
you guys all know this,
the first impression in life,
and even more so in
marketing, matters so much.
For you to be as tone
deaf to ask for money
from somebody who has
87,000 dollars in debt
and does not have a
job, you've pretty much
locked yourself out of
consideration, maybe forever.
And so if you do not CRM
those two groups out,
then that would be a
massive mistake to have
any sensibility in a 2016 data world,
where you should be able
to do that very easily.
I would play up a lot more is, you know,
I would do like a, and I'm
going really heavy with
my media, be a media company dreams,
but I would, I mean this is way
out there, so stick with me,
but I think there needs
to be like little videos
that you put out about stories of like
the serendipity of who
your college roommate is,
and what they meant to your life.
I think one of the, I mean,
maybe I'm super affected
by Adam Braun having Alex Soros as
his college roommate at Brown, but I think
the one conversation in my
land, which is very different
from academia, which is in
pure entrepreneur land,
is this is literally verbatim
of the 15 and 16-year-olds
that I talked to that
have been already accepted
into MIT and Stanford and
literally are asking me,
crap student, hey, should I go to college?
I've been accepted, I'm a 16-year-old,
I've been accepted to
MIT, but should I just
go to Silicon Valley
instead and do my thing?
And the one debate that is
happening at the level is,
ah but I'll get a good network
out of a bigtime school.
They are literally, and I
don't wanna be disrespectful,
I'm just giving you a lot of
information in conversation,
it is stunning how much, how little
they're valuing the education itself
or the ability for that
organization's logo to help them
at 22 to 24.
It is literally down to,
who are the other people?
And Alex, the reason I pitched you
a podcast for them to go and
like do a spotlight every week
on an alum, including housewife
to CEO of the biggest
company in the world.
You can't just go show your
52 best success stories,
was because I think that's an outrageously
important target of conversation.
- Yeah.
- And it is the value prop
that the best of the best
right now that are going
into the organization
are debating as the number one KPI.
Who are the seven people I'm gonna meet
that are gonna help me in the future?
Which has always been
there, but way more now,
way more now than I think we've ever seen.
And then again, once you make these,
the reason I'm kind of
like ramping on this,
and I'll let them go
through black and white,
is because we're gonna show you a lot of
black and white besides a
lot of hands up front stuff
which is very tactically thought about,
but once you decide what you want to
actually talk about, that becomes
the real thesis of success here.
- [Voiceover] Can I ask you one question,
you talk about videos a lot.
The level of sort of production?
- [Gary] You're talking
to a guy who broke out
on YouTube in the first year of YouTube,
and it looked like I was
a hostage in Afghanistan.
(laughs)
No lighting, no audio.
One of the biggest mistakes people make
is they over-think production.
Here's one I think, it
has never been easier
to make things look great for less money.
So first, don't let money,
like it it's gonna cost you,
do that, go with like whatever happens.
At the same token, I
think the younger it is,
so current, maybe just
your first few years out,
this man, the rest of the team
running around with iPhones,
more than enough.
More than enough.
I think over-produced
speaks to the insurance guy
with a business.
The more I could get you to be in a Snap,
versus great lighting and perfect makeup
and a nice-quality video,
that makes you just not,
it just doesn't allow
to associate with them.
Like, holy crap you were in a Snap!
Like that kind of, there's
a drawing in the bottom,
that like that relevancy
really matters to that demo.
As you age, I mean look, if
you're targeting your 60,
and 70 and 80-year-old alumni,
there's a debate, but
again, I'm so fearful
of the aging-down aspects
that are going on,
that I don't wanna go cliche, like okay,
if they're over this age,
do this, because the speed
at which the acceptance
of media consumption
in a younger kind of tactic
is happening very quickly.
So if it's costing you
money, I would punt that.
If for some reason you
could have the best lighting
and the best sound and there's no overhead
because you just happened
to have it there, sure,
but not for every situation.
So I really enjoyed the Brown meeting
because, you know,
whether it's universities,
nonprofits, people
trying to get voted for,
there's so many applications
of the modern day
communication shifts we're living through,
this whole social media, AKA slang term
for the modern web is
something you could apply
against anything in the world.
(mumbling)
And so, really liked spreading my wings
and talking to a prestigious university
about opportunities in the future.
- Can you sign this please?
- To?
- All of it's in there.
- Just Anthony.
- Yep.
Here are all the wires that you need,
and the one that I got you today should
charge your phone like eight times.
- For the rest of my life?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] (mumbles) you don't
play basketball anymore?
- [Voiceover] What's basketball?
- I think he said--
- [Staphon] That's all
anybody wants to know.
- Is that what he said?
- [Staphon] Did I make DailyVee?
- Did I make DailyVee?
(laughs)
- We're going to the Super Bowl?
- We're going to the Super Bowl, 100%.
You and I are sharing
a hotel, they only had
one hotel for us.
I said no problem, as
long as it has two beds.
- Even one bed, I like
it when we get cozy.
- I said I prefer two beds.
We'll deal with one bed if we have to.
Who besides me and you go to these games?
- Me and you.
- I know.
(mumbling)
- This Friday Clippers, right?
Make some progress in lieu of like
I wanna be there as much as possible.
(mumbles)
- Okay.
- So we don't need this call?
- We do not need this call.
There might be one or two
other things to talk about.
There's a list, it'll be quick,
it'll be super quick.
- Call me.
- I'm calling you, right now.
("You'll Like It" - Noah Lopez)